ايام قليله على انتهاء العام 2022 عام شهد
بدايه فصل جديد من الصراعات العالميه
وانطلاق الشراره الاولى لحرب اربكه العالم
اجمع في نهايه الشهر الثاني من العامل
2022 وتحديدا في ال 25 من فبراير انطلقت
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه حرب متواصله منذ
10 اشهر في تصعيد دون توقف بل ووفق
المؤشرات في عام 2023 سوف تدخل الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه الى نطاقات اكثر خطوره
وفقه مراقبين التحليلات هو المؤشرات تقول
ان الحربه مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات وان
العالم بعد 2022 ليعود ابدا الى هيكله
ونضمه التي كانت قائمه قبل الحرب العام
2012 سجل ايضا تصاعد التوتر بين الصين
وتايوان من جهه ويتدهر العلاقه بين الصين
وامريكا من جهه اخرى خاصه بعد زياره رئيسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي الى تايوان
بعيدا عن هذه المنطقه تتصاعد التحرشات
الكوريه الشماليه بجارتها الجنوبيه
وباليابان ايضا ما يرفع من التوقعات
المتشائمه ازاء الاستقرار في مناطق الشرق
الاسيوي
[موسيقى]
كيف سيكون عام 2023 في العالم موضوع
نناقشه مع ضيفي من القاهره الدكتور عبد
المنعم سعيد عضو مجلس الشيوخ ومن تونس
الدكتور خالد عبيد الباحث السياسي مرحبا
بكما ضيفيه الكريمين دكتور عبد المنعم
سعيد في القاهره ابدا معك في مقال لك
بالمصري اليوم ااا كتبت المقال بعنوان
2002 و 2023 عام خطر تتوقع في المقال
دكتور بان الحرب في اوكرانيا سوف تدخل الى
نطاقات اكثر خطوره ما هي هذه النطاقات
الخطيره برايك
هناك نطاق اول ليتمثل في زياره الرئيس
بوتين الى بيلروسيا وتوقيع اتفاقيات
للتعاون الدفاعي والامني صدور تهديدات من
بيلروسيا زياره زيلين سكي الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في ذكرى الخطاب الذي
القات شرشال في الكونجرس اثناء الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ايه حديث
هناك انه يعني الحرب في في اوكرانيا ليست
من اجل اوكرانيا وانها من اجل الامن
الدولي وامن الدول الغربيه وامن
الديمقراطيه اعلان التعبئه شبه تعبئه عامه
داخل روسيا لتوفير المزيد من الجنود في
الجبهه اعلانته يعني هناك كثير امور كثيره
جدا يعني بوت اعلن عن اسلحه جديده ليست
موجوده ايضا في الغرب وانه سوف يضرب
بطاريات باتري وتريلاتي سوف يحصل عليها زي
الينسكي وايضا معها 44 مليار دولار
هناك موجه كبيره من رفع موازنات الدفاع
عرفنا منها سابقا اا رفعها في المانيا
بحوالي 100 مليار دولار اليابان اعلنت هي
الاخرى انها سوف ترفع ميزانتها الدفاعيه
بقدر كبير يكفي لمواجهه التهديدات
الخارجيه همم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عملت قفزه كبيره جدا في انفاقها الدفاعي
من حوالي 700 مليار دولار الى 850 مليار
كل هذا يضعنا انا ماذا هل يضعنا امام
حتميه حرب عالميه ثالثا في 2023
يعني اللي اقدر اقوله انه دائما بيبقى
عندنا موازنه ما بين العمليات الحربيه وما
بين محاولات التسويه والتفاوض اييي اعتقد
انه يعني دائما دائما هناك فرصه للتفاوض
ووقف اطلاق النار وانما ارى ان كل
الاشارات تشير في الاتجاه المضاد حتى انه
جوزيف نايل المعلق الامريكي ولا الاستاذ
في العلاقات الدوليه الكبيره قال ان احنا
اذا ما سماها دبلوماتيك وينتر او شتاء
دبلوماسي اا بمعنى انه تقريبا لا يوجد اي
اشارات نحو بدء عمليه تسويه او السير في
اتجاهها والشتاء الحالي عاصف همم جدا يعني
الطقس اقصد في الولايات المتحده همم لا
نعلم هذا الشتاء الدبلوماسي كيف سيكون
ايضا في 23 دكتور خالد عبيد في تونس ويجدد
الترحيب همم اثبتت هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا
خلال عام 2022 ان كل التن همم والتحليلات
السياسيه يعني ما كانت تتوقع ان تحصل هذه
الحرب وان تقول الى ما الت اليه وان تستمر
حتى الان بهذا الشكل همم ما هي قراءتك
للعامل المقبل لحرب اوكرانيا نحاول ان
نستقرق قليله او نتنبا بما سيحمله العام
القادم همم وبدانا بالحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه لان الاهم تؤثر على العالم
جميعا همم كيف ترى تطورات او مالات هذه
الحرب في العامه الذي نستقبله بعد ايام
الدكتور خالد عبيد
مساء الخير استاذ سهيل هو في الواقع
بالنسبه لحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه لو نحن
رجعنا بالتاريخ قليلا الى فتره انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي ثم فيما بعد ما تولى
اييي بوريسيلتين الحكم ثم فريدمير بوتين
وخاصه مع تولي بوتين الحكم كان هناك شعور
لدابوتين بان هناك هذا حقيقي لروسيا ولذور
روسيا وبانونك رغبه بطريقه اخرى في محاسبه
روسيا استراتيجيا وجغرافيا سياسيه وكانت
هناك تحذيرات كبيره من بوتن في هذا المجال
لكن لم يقع تفطن اليها والاهتمام بها
والتركيز عليها الى ان حدث ما حدث في
اوكرانيا في فيفري المانيا لكن المعطى
الاساسي في كل هذا ان ما يحدث في اوكرانيا
اعتقادي والغزو الروسي او الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هي مؤشر على ان العالم لم يعد
كما كان واننا نحن الان ربما سنكون على
ابواب حرب بارده من نوعا اخر وانتيها
حقيقي للقطبيه الواحد التي رايناها بعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي فالعالم الان
احببنا امكرانه هو عالم متعدد الاقطاب
صحيح هناك قطب مهيمن منذ او منذ بدايه
التسعينات ويحاول لحد الان ان يبقى هو
المهيمن المطلق لكن في ذات الوقت هناك قوه
اخرى تحاول ان تفرض نفسها دوليه سواءا عن
مستوى السياسي وخاصه عن المستوى الاقتصادي
ونعني هنا الصين وروسيا لكن السؤال الذي
يسال هل ان الحرب الروسي الاوكرانيه ستكون
ستنتهي لا اعتقد ذلك لكن هل انها ستؤدي
بنا الى حرب عالميه ثالث مثل ما يذهب
البعض لا اعتقد ذلك ايضا بالنظر الى ان
القراءه
للعلاقات الدوليه وخاصه على المستوى
الجغراسيا لا اعتقد ان الولا تحت
الامريكيه بالرغم من انها تقوم بكل ما
لديها من جهد من اجل انهيك روسيا في هذه
الحرب من اجل اضعافها الى اقصى احد لكن عن
هذه الموسيقى
همم زياره الرئيس عبد العظيم البوتين الى
بيلاروسيا والاستعداد ربما الرئيس لوكا
شوكو ااه الجيش البيلاروسي للدخول الى ال-
الى الحرب ربما هناك من يعتقد انه الهدف
هو سيكون غزو العاصمه كيف من جهه اخرى
زياره كذلك الرئيس زينسكي همم الى
الولايات المتحده اثناء هذه الحرب بمعنى
القطبين مصممان على همم ربح هذه المعركه
همم الا يؤدي بنا هذا الى الصدام الاكبر
اضافه الى التوتر ما بين الصين والولايات
المتحده كما تفضلت وتحرشات بطييوان كذلك
كل هذا لا يجعل حتميه الصدام الاكبر والده
بشكل لا مفر منها في العام المقبل
لا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ستجاسف وتدخل في صراع مفتوحه مباشر مع
روسيا لانها تدرك جيدا انها ان دخلت في
هذا الصراع فان العالم كله سيفتح سيفتح
على المجهول نحن الان بسبب استنساخ ما سمي
في بدايه الحرب البارده الاولى ما سمي
بتوازن الرعب ما نشيده حاليا سواء من رغبه
اوكرانيه في اطاله قامت الحرب وتاييد
امريكي
من نوع من التذبذب الاوروبي ورغبه روسيه
في الحسن من خلال بيلاروسيا هذا لا يعني
ان سنشت سنشهدت تصاعدا اكثر فاكثر حرب قد
تذهب الى النووي لكن المشكله الاكبر هي ما
يحدث في جهه شرق اسيا بالنظر الى ان لدينا
الصين لن تقبل باي اتحاد من الاحوال انت
تصبح تايوان او فورموزا او الوطنيه خطر
انهدم مصالحه الاستراتيجيه في هذه المنطقه
وهي بذلك تحرك بطريقه او باخرى كوريا
الشماليه حليفه الاستراتيجي نعم دكتور عبد
المنعم سعيد عام 2023 الذين يترقبوا بعد
ايام هل يكون عاما لارساء النظام العالمي
الجديد متعدد الاقطاب همم خاصه بين الصين
والولايات المتحده ام لا هذا مجرد يعني
مبالغه وتبقى الولايات المتحده هي شرطي
العالم
لا انا يعني سنه ليست امدا كافيا حتى
نتحدث عن تغير في النظام
العالمي لا تزال التفاعلات تجري و نحن لا
نتحدث عن عالم متعدد الاقدام نحن نتحدث في
الحقيقه اما ان عالم ثلاثي الاقطاب في
روسيا والصين والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
او فيما اعتقد انا انه نتيجه هذه الحرب
سوف تكون عالما ثنائي الاقطاب مكونه هذه
المره من الولايات المتحده والصين لان
القطب الدولي هو القطب القادر على الوصول
اقتصاديا وعسكريا الى كل اركان الارض
وايضا الى الفضاء الخارجي وانا رغم ان
الولايات يعني انا روسيا لدي قوه عسكريه
نوويه تكفي لاباده الارض لكن ثبت من هذه
الحرب ان لديها يعني اا نقاط ان اكتشاف
خطيره همم ممثله في الجانب الاقتصادي انها
ليست ثم الولايات المتحده ولا الصين باي
معنى انما لديه قوه عسكريه بالفعل انها
قوه موجوده لكن هي لا تؤثر على على
الاسواق العالميه بالمعنى الانتاجي لا
اتحدث هنا عن عنصر الطاقه الذي تلعب فيه
دورا مهما فانا هقول ان التشكيل سوف ياخذ
وقتا لكن ايضا اقول ان اننا لن نكون لدينا
حرب نوويه وناموا ذلك لانه ربما اذا حدثت
حرب نوويه فلن نقوم بمقدرنا ان ان نقيم
هذا البرنامج مره اخرى ههه يعني فيها هنا
المساله اعتقد ان هناك ايضا الردع لا يزال
موجود لكن واضح انه عمليه التصعيد مستمره
وهذا ما اراه حادثه لا لا طبعا الحرب
الاوكرانيه هي الابرز همم والمصدر القلق
لانها تؤثر على الكثير من همم الملفات
الاخرى الاقتصاديه كذلك همم حول العالم
دكتور خالد عبيد في تونس اسالك عن همم
نقطه اخرى فيما يتعلق بالارهاب كذلك
هناك ايضا بعض التحضيرات والتقارير التي
تشير الى تنامي عوده خطر داعش في العام
المقبل 2023 وكذلك القاعده وتنظيمات
ارهابيه اخرى عن طريق الهجمات بالطائرات
المسيره عن طريق التجنيد عبر الانترنت عن
طريق الهجمات الالكترونيه والسيدبرانيه
همم الى اي حد تعتقد انه فعلا هذه
الجماعات الارهابيه التي اعتقدنا انها
انتهت
اوضاعفت بشكل كبير جدا على الاقل لها
امكانيه للعوده لعوده مزاوله النشاط
الارهابي
هو في الواقع هذه الجماعات الارهابيه لا
يمكن ان تنتهي باعتبار ان اسباب وجوده
تبقى دائما قائمه كانت من قبل القاعده ثم
فيما بعد راينا كيف القاعده انشطرت ثم
راينا من خلال الانشطار تكونا بطريقه او
باخرى داعش الذين راها قد ضعف كثيرا لكن
لا يمكن ان ينتهي داعش باعتبار حتى وان
انت داعش كتنظيم فبالتاكيد سيكون هناك
التنظيم اخر يحمل التسميه اخرى لكن سيكون
اكثر عنفا دمويه من التنظيمات التي سبقتها
وبالتاكيد هو الخوف كل الخوف من ان هؤلاء
الارهابيين بامكانهم ان يستعملوا احدث
التكنولوجيات والتقنيات المتطوره من اجل
استعمالها في عمليه استعراضيه غايته
بطريقه باخرى زرع مزيد من الرعب والخوف
والتبيين بان هذه جماعه تبقى دائما قادره
على الاثقان وقادر على الايلين انه لا
يمكن هذا الغرب الذي تعتبره الغرب الكافر
لا يمكن بان ينهي وي- ويقوم بمؤامرته ضد
العالم الاسلامي في وجه حسبه وجهه نظرها
ولهذا السبب اعتقادي مثل ما راينا ان داعش
استعمل التكنولوجيه خاصه على مستوى
التواصل الاجتماعي وعمليه التجنيد
الالكتروني فبالامكان ان يقع هناك التطور
في هذه الناحيه وهذه تتطلب بيقذ دوليه ولا
تكون يقظه مقتصر على هذه الدوله او تلك
لان هذه الجريمه الارهابيه او الارهاب
اصبح عابرا للقارات وبالتالي يجب ان تكون
هناك يقظه عابر القارات ايضا
وتعكيب صغير بالنسبه للعالم الذين شده
الان نحن الان قلت في بدايات الحرب
البارده متعدده الاقطاب وانت ما يكون هناك
ثلاثيه يعني اننا خرجنا من القطب الواحد
ومن الثنائيه وتخنى في التعدد
ووافق الدكتور سعيد عندما يتحدث عن الويه
تحت امريكيه ككتب سيبقى موجودا لكن الصين
ايضا وحتى روسيا لا يمكن ان ننسى ان روسيا
تشعر دائما بالغوبل التاريخي باعتبار ان
اوروبا والغرب يعتبرها دائما
على ذكر الغبن التاريخ الدكتور عبد المنعم
بسؤال مدام نتحدث عن عام 2023 هو العام
الذي تنقضي فيه معاهده لوزان التي وقعت في
عام 1923 مرت عليها 100 عام والتي انهت
همم يعني الامبراطوريه العثمانيه همم وهذا
يدفعنا للحديث عن همم عن التجابات كذلك
بين تركيا ودول الشرق المتوسط بين تركيا
والدول العربيه همم كذلك ما هي توقعاتك مع
انتهاء هذه المعاهده في العام الداخل
يعني واضح انه
الحمله التركيه الى حد كبير كان فيها جزء
يتعلق بالجانب الروسي ان الامبراطوريات
القديمه تعود مره اخرى الى التفكر
تاريخها القديم او الحنين الى الماضي
الاتحاد السوفيتي كانت هناك كانت هناك
الجمهوريات التي تتحدث التركيه فالعالم
التركي التاسع بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي ومع وجود اردوغان وشخصياته فانه
الحديث عن العثمانيه الجديده كان يتضمن
قدرا من ذلك لكن اعتقد ان التجربه الاعوام
ال- ال- الماضيه يعني ابتدت تكتشف ان ان
ذلك سوف يكون مكلفا لتركيا لذلك فهي حتى
الان لا يزال موقعها مركزا على مساله
التعامل مع حزب العمال الكردستاني الذي
يشكل تهديدا ثانيا
لتركيا ولذلك فهناك انواع من استخدام
للقوه العسكريه في مواجهه العراق وسوريا
وايضا ليبيا وشرق البحر الابيض المتوسط
لكن انا لا اظن انه على الطريقه الروسيه
وانما هناك حدود وهناك ايضا يعني حال
التهدئه عامه عموما في هذه الجبهه طيب
جاريه الان يعني اخيرا شيء ربما اا يبعث
على التفاؤل مع هذه السنه الجديده دكتور
خالد عبيد تحدثنا عن يعني كل المؤشرات
تشير الى همم اتساع النطاق الحرب
الاوكرانيه همم تغير النظام العالمي او
تبدله بشكل تدريجي كذلك خطر الارهاب يعود
من جديد كل هذه الاشياء متشائمه للعام
الجديد هل من اي شيء ايجابي نترقبه في
العام المقبل
هو بالتاكيد يجب ان نبقى اولا متفائلين
وربما من من فرد التشاؤم الذي نلاحظه في
هذه السنه التي مرت علينا والتي تعقب ازمه
كورونا خاصه يجب ان لا ننسى انه ربما سنشد
في هذه السنه تبدل وتغيرا على عده مستويات
ومنها حتى على مستوى الحرب الروسي
الاوكرانيه لانه ليس هناك اي شيء يمنع من
ان تنتهي في ايه لحظه خاصه اذا ما رات
البيت من تحت الامريكيه ان هذه الحرب يجب
ان تنتهي بالنظر الى تضرر مصالحها لكن هل
ان الوليد ضحك امريكيه هم ومصالح اوروبا
لا نعتقد ذلك ما الذي هم اكثر هي مصالحها
فهذا العالم اعتقد انه سنشد فيه نوعا من
توازن اهميه التوازن الرعب وفي توازن
الرعب بالتاكيد سيقع ثلاثه العديد من
المحظورات تلازم لو توازن الرعب هو الذي
جنب حربا العالم حرب عالميه حرب النوويه
وذلك اثر الازمه الاتحاد حدثت بين الولد
تحت الامريكيه والاتحاد السوفيتي على اكثر
ازمه الصواريخ في كوبا يعني هذه المساله
يجب ان ننظر اليها من زاويه اننا من كثره
التشاؤم بالتاكيد سيكون هناك التفاؤل نعم
نتمنى على كل حال يحمل العام الجديد اخبار
ساره واوضاع عن همم يعني ليست سيئه للغايه
على العموم شكرا جزيلا لكمين من القاهره
دكتور عبد المنعم سعيد عضو مجلس الشيوخ من
تونس الدكتور خالد عبيد الباحث السياسي
[موسيقى]